[Music]
hello hello how you doing hi
I like all real [ __ ] in front of me and
all [ __ ] aside I've been sick with
it my whole life and I didn't even die
yo bro 200,000 raps and never had to lie
how much passion to the price twice and
I didn't even cry got the flush of a
record deal rimmel rimmel is inouye
that's his intern Bernard yo we've been
going hard for like three years
hey Owen I got a show Owen is a rapper
Oh cute tonight this show is gonna get
us the deal that's about eight murdering
that mic out there and that's what's
believed do you think various ma'am I
know this will come as no surprise than
anyone here but Wiz Khalifa has some
incredibly strong weed
Yao's the one they know so well will
recognize really uh neighboring no doubt
yo is this it is strong so they callin
em Caesar boy and they even have a
seizure
damn your seizure boy this guy stake a
fortune he's done let it go your rap
career it's not over in ninth grade I
told you and if you let me be your
manager I would go ham for you tonight
the after party to end all after parties
everyone in the game will be there
French Montana
yo just push your teeth all you have to
do is spit a fire verson and we got
ourselves a record deal got a plan to
get us in the kid always comes through
in the clutch the kid rarely comes
through in the clutch
yeah she's got a point the kid basically
never comes through in the clutch if
y'all want to get in here come back with
a whole lot of [ __ ] I don't come back
at all do you want to come to the
after-party
no how do we get a record deal before
the Sun Rise
[Music]
you gotta chew man plus up what's up
what's up
you